Never have I ever kissed a girl
it I wanted to know
up
[inaudible]. I'm Corey brothers
or [inaudible]. My name's Rj.
You've been rather it's for 18 right?
18 years.
Now that I think about it, we don't talk
as much, but like we get each other.
All right. Never have I ever
made you clean up my mess.
Hey,
yeah.
Remember when your friend brought home
like a BB gun and we're not allowed.
We weren't allowed to shoot at the time.
As
I told Mom, knowing that she
directly anger towards you
because she was like, oh,
you're the older brothers Lee out
to like be a role model and stuff.
Have you felt guilty about that?
I think I should
have got you in trouble, but I don't
know. Time heals all wounds, dude.
I said yes because I thought you meant
like a literal messy room in some ways.
I don't want you to take care of my mess
if I can't be a good role model to you.
Then like
what's the point of me being
your older brother? Biologically,
I'm your older brother, but I want
to be an older brother. You know,
okay.
Never have I ever, never have I ever
done something to fit in very to what,
what did you do to fit in?
So my friend was like,
oh do you don't have in this kickback
am I my house and stuff. Right.
I didn't know what a kickback
was. Right. So I want anyways.
And I kinda like found
out while I was there.
I don't think of myself as wanting
to succumb to like peer pressure.
But I did that one time and it was,
it was really stupid because like those
aren't even like my actual friends,
you know? It was just like a
bunch of people I met that night.
I know you're the older brother,
but I'm still an older
brother to like our sisters.
I don't want to like be open
with it. Right. All right.
I didn't want to like tell you one of the
family cause I know like stuff travels.
Yes.
They understand that. Like
it was something that you
didn't want to do then. Yeah.
But they don't have to know that. I don't
think I've had something like yours.
I think it was just back in middle
school with my tight pants. Oh yeah.
Uh, never. Have I ever
lied to you? They a law.
No surprise as I feel like I've lied to
you and you knew it and then you lied to
me. I knew it. Yeah.
I would always like come up with some
like bullshit excuse that. Oh my,
like rising turnout or something.
So I need you try me when I actually
just like totally forgot to ask you. Uh,
uh, let's see. What
have I lied to? I Dunno.
I just feel like I just try and make
myself sound better than I usually do.
Never have I ever been afraid
of the future? Three to one.
Pretty sure everyone
our age is freaking out.
Going in a film, it's like, I
don't really know what to do.
I know a lot of people freelance.
I was with my friend and he told me
that the best way to get through,
just to follow the rules, you have to
be a doctor, engineer or business major.
Right. Those are like social
standards for kids like us.
And when he told like said that to me,
I was like super paranoid
when I got into USC is like sweet.
I know the direction that I'm going in
but I still have no idea like what I'm
supposed to do.
It's scary cause like mom and dad are
investing in us so much like everyone that
I've talked to, like it's the same
thing like no one has it figured out.
Cool, cool, cool.
Never have I ever wanted to
tell you something but didn't
to spare your feelings?
No. Countdown God. Well now okay.
My bad feels quite awkward.
I can't think of any.
I mean it's all the same thing.
I know you can do better,
you know that kind of thing.
Like there are things I wanted to tell
you but like I knew you already felt it
up until now. For the longest
time I thought you had
everything like sorted out.
Growing up with you,
you are so optimistic about everything
and there was never a time where I felt
like I had to tell you something.
A lot of the things I tell you anyways.
It's just like it turns into
like this like joke are.
We just like laugh it
off and it's like cool.
I'm like a role model to, you
know, I look up with Jaylen,
never have I ever felt like I
disappointed you in three, two,
one
wait, I still into your process.
I need you. You took your first.
It's like the same thing I've been
saying like whenever mom yells at me or
whenever I feel like I messed up,
that's when I feel like I've disappointed
you and Jaylen and Kina like I just
wanted to be this big blanket for you
guys to like be safe and I think when you
left for college you left some
like pretty big shoes to fill.
You know what I mean?
And
it didn't feel as like super gradual.
It just felt like all
these responsibilities were
dumped on me and it was like
that expectation to be you like literally.
Yeah and body,
like your personality and mannerisms.
Like,
I don't want you to like come back and
find out like her family's like super
screwed up and stuff. You
know what I mean? Yeah.
Cause like you guys in shambles right
now? No, I'm just kidding. We're great.
Is that a lie? Are you guys okay?
Yeah, we're fine. Are you okay?
Are you okay? I'm killing it
here too. Yeah, I'm lit dude.
We were just talking about you.
Okay. The more you ask him, no more.
I'm concerned like,
I don't think I've talked to you as much.
I just want to make sure that you're okay.
Keep your top like here all the time.
Okay. Okay. You guys okay?
We're great. How do you feel?
Okay.
I feel like we've both felt this way.
We just never like talked about it.
It's like understandable.
Like I don't expect them to talk
to me about these kinds of things.
We've known each other for 18 years now,
so I can like understand you
without having to like ask you or,
yeah. Talk about it. Hey, do you want
him to play one more question? Okay.
Never have I ever kissed the girl.
I wanted to. No surprise. There were
times when like I thought [inaudible].
He's like the ladies, man. I don't
know how he gets all these girls.
He's like the silent
mysterious guy. I'm like, man,
for the longest time I've always
wanted to kiss, kiss the girl,
Dude,
you are incredible.
Look at us coming together and watching
the videos together. Such a family, right?
Yeah.
We got more stuff for you right here to
subscribe and we have one video smooth.
We got all types of stuff. Anyway,
until next time, peace out.